[Musique]
bonjour de brielles enchanté nicolas
contrat comme ça c'est la première fois
depuis deux ans que gabriel met les
pieds dans son école de danse son refuge
et sa passion
c'est ici qu'il brillait sur les
planches
e
c'est comme une drogue je voudrais
surtout le rabin assassiné
dans une auto radio petit stress est
ravie de
décoller à danser je courais
besoin d à l'image assez que c'est que
je décolle à danser
je crois c'est quelque chose
gabriel à 20 ans elle est atteinte d'un
mal mystérieux qui a brisé son corps et
ses rêves qu'est ce que tu vois
je suis lancé
[Musique]
il y un peu plus de 24 mois gabriel
était étudiante à l'université mount
allison de sackville l'une des
meilleures écoles au pays c'était le
lundi avant l'aube j'avais cet émoi en
poupe sa demie tao quelque chose comme
ça et
j'ai été touché et je me réveille à cinq
heures et demie du soir
l'homme aurait dit l'un d'eux mêmes
elle est réveillée par un ami qui cogne
avec insistance à la porte de sa
résidence
gabriel a dormi pendant presque 24
heures à l'amant qui tous ses cours
mais il avait pigé d'accord
avec pour
vingt secondes j'ai pu me rendre à la
pro à moitié aveugle je te tom
post amm mon ami ils me posaient des
questions aux biches me disais qu'est
choix pour monter juste trop mal
bizarrement et puis a dit ok non on va
longer ans
les médecins soupçonnent une
mononucléose
mais les résultats des tests sont
négatifs
gabriel retournent chez elles sans
comprendre ce qui lui arrive pendant
deux mois son état de santé se détériore
elle a mal aux jambes des problèmes d'
équilibre des problèmes de vision n
aille pas à manger et perd du poids pour
comprendre le mal qui l'affligent sa
médecin de famille l'arrêt faire un
neurologue de moncton le docteur al hier
marc ayrault
mon bras et mains tremblaient c'était
comme si ma tête se faisait écraser
quand elle l urgence et ils m'ont vu
tout de suite parce qu'on pensait que
c'était un wc
la santé de carole clark se dégradent
déjà depuis plusieurs mois lorsqu'elles
se présentent à l'urgence d'un hôpital
de moncton avec son mari en juin 2020
perte d'appétit tremblements douleur
insupportable auxquels
nos résidences doutait que ce n'est pas
un avc
il a décidé de l'hospitaliser
il m'indique un euro viendraient me voir
comme gabriel corps me carole clark y
référer aux neurologues alliant marc
ayrault
il m'a posé plein de questions
on file disant est ce que tu as déjà
fait ci ou ça es tu déjà les syriens il
m'a soigné pendant une semaine à
l'hôpital pendant qu'on faisait passer
des tests je pense au travers de toutes
les tests que tu peux passer au travail
je me fais ok avec des aiguilles pour
tous venir j'ai passé des
habitants
[Musique]
malgré la multiplication des examens le
docteur marc ayrault n'arrive pas à
identifier
de quoi souffrent les deux femmes
en novembre 2020 carole clark est au
plus mal elle sent qu'il lui reste peu
de temps à vivre elle déménage en
ontario pour se rapprocher de sa fille
et de ses huit petits-enfants
c'était hallucinant de la voir descendre
de la voiture a connu
je ne pouvais pas en croire mes yeux
c'est ni comment ça m'avait échappé
durant toutes nos conversations
gabriel aussi voit son état de santé
décliner
faut pas la micro petit issa des moins
que rien
elle quitte l'université et retourne
vivre chez ses parents
en mars 2021 le docteur marc ayrault
l'informent qu'elle n'est pas seule à
souffrir
le seul temps caire
j'ai su que je faisais partie du groupe
de
personnes c'était
juste une coupe un jour avant que
facile l'immédiat une maladie inconnue
frappe le nouveau brunswick
16 mars 2021 nous recevons une enveloppe
d'une source confidentielle
le document qu'elle contient un mémo de
la santé publique de la province révèle
l'existence d'un syndrome d'origine
inconnue qui aurait frappé 40 citoyens
cette note interne dont on obtenu copie
on peut on peut y lire qu'il ya donc une
une grappe de cap du syndrome
neurologique progressive d'étiologie
inconnu le groupe de patients est
composée de citoyens de 18 à 85 ans
autant par des hommes que des femmes ils
ont tous résident et au nouveau
brunswick cinq personnes en seraient
décédés
nouvelle provoque une onde de choc il
force la ministre de la santé de la
province à réagir
nous mettons en place une clinique avec
l'aide du docteur marc ayrault
les patients ont les mêmes symptômes
cliniques troubles de mémoire perte de
coordination des mouvements changement
le comportement hallucinations visuelles
une vision floue atrophie musculaire
c'était comme un historique privé de les
derniers une ans et demi de mon père
parce que ils avaient tous les symptômes
qui était mentionné dans la high tech
steve ellis est le fils de roger ellis
un homme de 64 ans qui serait atteint
lui aussi par ce mal mystérieux
on pensait que c'était seulement les
hausses étaient seulement lui c'était un
mystère mais juste pour une personne
[Musique]
le 23 juin 2019 roger élise fête ses 40
ans de mariage lorsqu'il ressent une
douleur à la poitrine son fils pense
qu'il fait une crise cardiaque
il emmène à l'hôpital le malaise
cardiaque et écarté roger retourne à la
maison mais le soir même il fait des
convulsions de retour à l'hôpital son
état se détériore rapidement
il perd la mémoire à court terme il a
des hallucinations des spasmes
musculaires et des douleurs
chose qui était je pense plus difficile
il y avait aucune raison il y avait
aucun
diagnostic
la famille de roger ellis assiste
impuissante à son déclin depuis presque
deux ans
le docteur marc ayrault qui suit roger
ils y pensent qu'il est lui aussi
atteint du nouveau syndrome
[Musique]
et oui c'était en janvier 2019 du
maintien oui on venait tout juste de
célébrer noël
et j'avais remarqué que papa était plus
tranquille qu'à l'habitude et
moyennement
le riz biti le père de gilles et tim
beatty est une des cinq premières
victimes qui seraient décédées du
nouveau syndrome
125 quelque chose est arrivé et c'est
arrivé rapidement ce qu'ils publient
qu'ils n'étaient plus en contact avec la
réalité pointures
les médecins soupçonnent la maladie de
creutzfeldt jakob une maladie neuro
dégénératifs monsieur b timmer cinq mois
après l'apparition des symptômes et la
famille demande une autopsie
ni en transe et oise de l'autopsié a
révélé un résultat négatif à la maladie
de creutzfeldt jakob
on n'a que des mousseaux lès lens
pendant presque deux ans la famille
beatty s'est demandé de quoi le riz
beatty étaient décédés le docteur marc
ayrault qui a examiné monsieur beatty
avant sa mort crois qu'il a été emporté
par le nouveau syndrome
pourquoi est-ce que gardel qui est vain
et
très malade comme on part comme carole
somme pour moi ça ajoute que c'est un
mystère c'est peut-être quelque chose de
nouveau qui affecte tout le monde
[Musique]
les patients sont répartis sur environ
300 km qui sont principalement issus des
régions du nord-est du nouveau-brunswick
et de moncton
46 des 48 cas ont été identifiés par le
docteur al hier marc ayrault un fait que
la province va éventuellement utilisés
pour semer le doute
un médecin il va devenir un personnage
important dès le début de cette affaire
le docteur marc ayrault il suit certains
patients et va sonner l'alerté il
pourrait s'agir d'un nouveau syndrome
qui est causé par quelque chose dans
l'environnement
risquait la peine depuis plusieurs mois
gabriel cormier document de ses
symptômes et ses caprices c'est
le 16 nov à
12h55
hicham fais mal par le mal d'habitude
madame ramener mal musculaire
la jeune femme perd peu à peu le
contrôle de son corps elle a de plus en
plus de difficultés à se concentrer
une news que j'adorerais apprendre jal
aurelio j'adorais juste savoir des
choses justes à princes
gabriel voulait devenir médecin une
pathologiste gagnante de plusieurs
bourses l étudier les sciences à
l'université
mais son rêve a pris fin remplacé par
des visites fréquentes à l'hôpital et à
la clinique du docteur al hier marc
ayrault
quelques semaines la mauvaise nouvelle
je pouvais à boire dans sa phase que ça
faisait mal de même dire
les qualités humaines et
professionnelles du docteur marc ayrault
sont appréciés chez ces patients
il était merveilleux c'était mon sauveur
c'était lui que je fais le plus
confiance dans toute cette affaire mon
père était très malade mais quand le
docteur marc ayrault venait le voir on
apercevait un changement physique chez
lui il était plus calme
bonjour bâtard docteur marc ayrault est
un médecin en mission
ne pas trouver des moustiques ce n'est
pas une réponse à un patient il faut
continuer qu'il faut faire tous les
efforts jusqu'à ce qu'on un trou
il est reconnu par ses pairs comme un
spécialiste des maladies rares
c'est un sujet qui le passionne
l'année diagnostic et plusieurs et on a
découvert plusieurs nouvelles maladies
rares ici complet maladies
mitochondriales des dystrophies
musculaires que nous avons commencé à
publier
la plupart des patients dont nous
connaissons l'identité ont été référées
au docteur marc ayrault par ses
collègues médecins
loyers de plus en plus de cas est de
plus en plus des jeunes à mesure que le
temps passait donc ces points-là est
devenue comme une alerte selon la santé
publique du nouveau brunswick on
dénombrait déjà treize cartes du
syndrome neurologique inconnu en 2019 il
y a deux ans dès lors le docteur marc
ayrault suspecte l'émergence d'une
nouvelle maladie mais demeure prudent je
commence par le doute avant ça des
adhérents chaque patient ma première
hypothèse
ce n'est pas intéressé et donc c'est la
mort a dit non et l'âme des critères que
nous avons une malice et en élimine
d'alcool
les symptômes des patients ressemble à
une forme rare et mortelle d'un troubles
neurocognitifs la maladie de creutzfeldt
jakob une variante humaine de cette
maladie aussi appelé la vache folle a
déjà fait les manchettes dans les années
90 à cette période ottawa a établi un
système de surveillance nationales et
exige que ces maladies soit rapporté à
l'agencé de santé publique du canada le
problème dans le cas du syndrome de
cause inconnue au nouveau brunswick
c'est que les cas rapportés sont tous
négatifs il ya quand même un travail de
surveillance et 3 pour venir à la
conclusion après les consultations avec
beaucoup espèrent que ces gens là
avaient des points communs qui ressemble
à une nouvelle maladie le docteur marc
ayrault avec des scientifiques de l'
agence de la santé publique du canada
travaille sur l'élaboration d'une
définition pendant près d'un an
fin 2020 le groupe de travail fédéral
provincial chargé d'étudier la grappe
accouche d'une définition provisoire du
nouveau syndrome
mais c'est seulement à la suite de nos
révélations du mémo le 16 mars 2021 que
la médecin hygiéniste en chef de la
province confirme l'existence du
syndrome est probablement une nouvelle
maladie nous n'avons pas vu ça ailleurs
donc c'est une maladie dont l'idéologie
est inconnu pour les patients du docteur
marc ayrault apprendre qu'ils font
partie d'une grappe de cas redonne un
peu d'espoir
ces machins à dire que je suis content
que ya d'autre part cela comme moi pas
tout seul
ça mais aussi que je fait seul et en
fait pour une investigation
maintenant que l'existence d'un nouveau
syndrome est publique les choses se
mettent en branle en avril 2021 une
clinique spéciale dédiée aux personnes
atteintes est ouverte à moncton en
continuant à faire des emplettes eddy
richer je suis aussi en eau des
communications au niveau national parce
qu'on soupçonne que le syndrome pourrait
être lié à une toxine d'origine végétale
animale ou alimentaires plusieurs
ministères vient de prêter main forte
aux autorités de la santé publique
provinciale et fédérale
tout le monde travaille ensemble dans un
seul but trouver la cause de la maladie
inconnue il faut faire vite 48 malades
sont recensés
six sont décédés c'est le docteur marc
ayrault qui mène l'enquêté et à des
tests qui doivent être faits pour moi
ces toxines sont dans le cerveau par
exemple et dans les tissus dans les
grands à la fois de son côté la santé
publique de la province amorce une
enquête épidémiologique
essentiellement composée d'un sondage
téléphonique
lorsqu'il vend luc leblanc 41 ans est un
des 48 patients qui seraient atteints du
syndrome en juin 2021 il est interrogé
par une infirmière de la santé publique
pendant cinq heures
[Musique]
histoire chirurgicale lieu de résidence
alimentation environnement et
antécédents familiaux l'objectif est de
découvrir des facteurs communs entre les
patients
[Musique]
il a failli
et puis l'équipe a d'abord beaucoup de
symptômes de l'ucl blanc ont commencé à
la suite d'une commotion cérébrale
survenue lors d'un accident de voiture
il ya trois ans à l'époque ces médecins
de famille leur fr en neurologie mais la
liste d'attenté est longue il ne sera
pas en mesure de voir un neurologue
avant deux ans
je ne vais plus d' équilibre des motos
des engourdissements
comme si je portais
en octobre 2020 l'hôpital georges dumont
demande tonnes appelle luc leblanc pour
lui donner enfin un rendez vous il y a
quatre neurologue à l'hôpital par hasard
monsieur leblanc tombe sur le docteur
marc ayrault après avoir étudié son
dossier est réalisé des tests
supplémentaires
le docteur marc ayrault lui annonce
qu'il a le cerveau d'un homme beaucoup
plus âgé
nsn j'ai demandé
si c'était causés par mon accident de
voiture il m'a dit non
ce sont des problèmes dégénératif et
celle ci m'a dit qu'il avait d'autres
patients qui avaient les mêmes mots que
si tu as quelque chose dans
l'environnement
mais sans nommer la maladie mystérieuse
mais luc leblanc est sceptique il trouve
que les notes prises par le docteur marc
ayrault dans son dossier médical ne
correspondent pas tout à faire ce qu'il
a dit de plus il estime que ces
symptômes sont différents des autres
patients ont connu jusqu'à maintenant
au début j'y croyais presque à 100%
jusqu'à ce que j'aie ses papiers et que
je me présente à son bureau
je lui ai montré les papiers et je lui
dis faut comprendre j'ai beaucoup de
questions
mais j'ai senti que lui son assistante
ne voulait pas entrer dans les détails
découvrir une nouvelle maladie est
exceptionnel des confrères du docteur
marc ayrault comme la neurologue valérie
sim de l'université d'alberta se pose
des questions
est ce que ça pourrait être une nouvelle
toxines qui dans des conditions
favorables à causerait ce nouveau
syndrome
chinois est ce possible
oui
mais nous devons également être ouverts
à l'idée est que ce n'est pas le cas que
c'est simplement un groupe de patients
ayant des symptômes comme un symptôme
mais c'est ce que je serais porté à
croire que le doute oui et c'est
important est de le garder mais à quand
vous commencez à avoir beaucoup des gens
qui ont la même qu'à la qualité
il ya quelque chose en commun qui
arrivent et qui doivent vérifier qui
doit être étudiée et luc leblanc veut en
avoir le coeur net avec notre aide il va
obtenir un deuxième avis médical
l'udc va se faire examiner demain le 27
octobre 2021 par la docteure lorraine
kalia de l'hôpital toronto western une
des plus grandes spécialistes sur le
parkinson au pays mais si vous trouvez
les réponses plus les réponses que j'ai
eues dans les diagnostics a dit trouver
c'est un modèle non
[Musique]
ouah
les désaccords entre scientifiques ça
fait partie de la science sauf que dans
le cas du mal étrange au nouveau
brunswick c'est carrément le
gouvernement qui semble vouloir
discréditer le docteur marc ayrault est
ce qu une question de santé publique
serait devenu politique
je suis heureux de nouvelle écosse à
base de vos besoins pour visiter mon
temps et mon famille en raison de la
pandémie steve ellis n'a pas vu son père
depuis dix mois pour famille c'est très
longtemps que je t aime parce que
bergson conditions on sait pas combien
de voir qui peut vivre
[Musique]
steve ellis est extrêmement critique de
la façon dont le gouvernement provincial
a géré le dossier de la nouvelle maladie
difficile de leur faire confiance quand
on ne sait pas exactement ce qu'ils font
au printemps 2021 quelque chose a
basculé soudainement le discours de la
province change
le syndrome ou ses causes n'ayant pas
encore été identifié nous évitons de
dire qu'il est confirmée ou
diagnostiquer
la ministre de la santé ne parle plus
d'un nouveau syndrome mais d'un
potentiel syndrome la province vient en
quelque sorte de désavouer l'existence
de la maladie ce qui est très mal
accueillie par les patients et leurs
familles
et dire que c'est un syndrome potentiel
parce que on a aucun doute qu'il ya
quelque chose qui va mal ce changement
de discours arrive alors que l'idée
d'une cause environnementale et reprise
par plusieurs médias nationaux je
comprends et c'est d'être subjectif cela
que la question de toxines
environnemental fait peur et que ça
bloque tout
le nouveau syndrome pourrait avoir un
lien avec les éclosions de
cyanobactéries minet mans appelées
algues bleu-vert on avait plus en plus
d'inclusion dans l'hiver l'été ça c'est
une hypothèse je n'ai pas que c'est ça
mais c'est une hypothèse qui est
considérée et qu'on doit analyser les
cyanobactéries pourrait affecter la
chaîne alimentaire les crustacés par
exemple si l'hypothèse d'un lien entre
leur contamination il le nouveau
syndrome s'avéraient fondées cela
pourrait être dévastateur pour
l'industrie du tourisme et de la pêche
on ne veut peut-être pas savoir trop
vite si c'est une cause environnementale
parce qu'on gère déjà l'impact
économique de la commune iv lanteigne
est la directrice de blood watch un
groupe de pression nationale de défense
des patients elle n'est pas surprise par
la tournure des événements la politique
s'est ingéré dans chacune des crises
sanitaires au cours des 100 dernières
années dans chacune d'elles
le docteur marc ayrault n'est pas le
seul à avoir émis l'hypothèse que le
nouveau syndrome pourraient être causés
par les cyanobactéries en mai 2021 dans
une entrevue à la radio le neurologue ni
cashman de l'université de la
colombie-britannique abondé dans le même
sens
jusqu'au printemps dernier le docteur
cashman faisait partie du groupe de
travail fédéral provincial chargé
d'étudier la grappe du nouveau brunswick
comme tous les experts de ce groupe que
nous avons tenté de joindre le docteur
cashman n'accorde plus d'entrevues un
autre scientifique proche du dossier
nous a dit avoir été muselés
c'est troublant quand un scientifique ne
peut pas parler ouvertement et
l'investigation ne devrait pas être
influencées par la politique elles
devraient être gérée comme une crise de
santé publique
sur un point la majorité des
scientifiques s'entendent il faut le
plus rapidement possible permettre aux
experts nationaux et internationaux de
se rendre sur le terrain pour faire des
tests environnementaux et évaluer les
patients mais ce n'est pas ce que le
nouveau-brunswick va faire
toutes les ressources devraient être
consacrés à trouver l'origine du
syndrome
c'est frustrant et inquiétant
pourquoi le gouvernement dit la santé
publique du canada ne met il pas
l'investigation
alors que depuis des mois les experts
fédéraux et provinciaux tiennent des
réunions le 6 mai 2021 le ministère de
la santé suspend le processus de
collaboration
il invoque les besoins de prendre une
pause pour fouiller plus à fond les
données existantes sur le syndrome
neurologique dans les semaines qui
suivent la province demande au groupe de
travail national de se retirer il prend
le contrôle de l'enquète les experts de
maladies neurodégénératives et
d'épidémiologie de toxicologie au pays
était supposé devenir au nouveau
brunswick
physiquement avec un appui massif pour
la recherche avec un budget qu'avait
émis les côtés avec une émanation
directe des patients et avec des tests
sur les patientes des tissus et
l'environnement
soudainement s'était interrompue en juin
la ministre de la santé dit que
dorénavant il n'y aura plus de nouveaux
patients ajoutés au groupe de 48 cas et
ce même si des médecins pensent que
d'autres personnes semblent en être
atteinte nos patients qui sont mal on en
a beaucoup plus des jeunes dans la
clinique à tout moment si plus qu'une
plus qu'une centaine
le site web mise en ligne pour informer
la population cesse d'être mise à jour
temporairement la province s'enfonce
dans le mutisme
ils ne répondent pas aux questions du
public il manque de transparence avec
les patients à gaza à mon avis c'est
inacceptable pourquoi est-ce que du real
parce qu'il ya quelque chose qui il veut
pas partager maintenant c'est vraiment
décourageant
la ministre de la santé annonce la
création d'un comité de surveillance du
syndrome il est composé de six
neurologues du nouveau brunswick le
docteur marc ayrault et le groupe de
travail fédéral ne font pas partie du
groupe
j'ai jamais compris pourquoi parce qu'on
nous sommes depuis le début très disposé
à collaborer pour tout ce qui est
possible de faire pour nos patients
le mandat du comité et de réévaluer
l'ensemble des dossiers médicaux et
déterminer si les patients sont bel et
bien liés entre eux
ce n'est pas pour contrôler le message
mais pour s'assurer qu'on offre à la
population du nouveau brunswick une
information exacte et vallée de vinchy
[Musique]
ce n'est pas encore été dit de façon
aussi tranchée et définitive mais le
gouvernement du nouveau brunswick ne
crois pas qu'il existe une toxine qui a
causé une nouvelle maladie sauf que la
méthode employée par la province pour
conclure en ce sens ça tire beaucoup de
critiques des doutes planent sur
l'existence de la maladie de cause
inconnue au nouveau brunswick raid 6
octobre 2021 l'histoire du mystérieux
syndrome prend une tournure inattendue
on apprend que les résultats des
autopsies pratiquées sur huit patients
qui étaient soupçonnés d'en être
atteints sont publiés
nicholas yen pointe vers l'existence de
nouvelles maladies voilà c'est un
rapport qu'on a obtenu aujourd'hui marie
hélène et qui a été publiée par le
neuropathologiste le 7 octobre 2021 je
cite son rapport il indique aucune trace
de maladies à prions n'a été trouvé ni
aucune trace d'une nouvelle pathologie
nous suggérons que les huit patients
font partie d'un groupe de diagnostic
mal classés ce qu'on a pour les familles
des patients décédés sont sous le choc
elles n'ont pas été prévenus de la
publication je suis vraiment déçu que
les familles de les huit caisses aidées
l'était pas encore avoir les médias sans
indiquer la cause de la mort des
patients le rapport sommaire du
pathologiste identifie qu'il souffrait
entre autres de cancer d'alzheimer et de
la maladie accord de lévis
ah mais oui mais on a été consternée de
savoir que les résultats de taupe s'y
était rendu public
c'était horrible pour la fameuse faille
tout à fait moins
le lendemain les patients et leurs
familles encaisse un deuxième coup dur
la ministre de la santé du
nouveau-brunswick dévoile les
conclusions de l'enquêté épidémiologique
commencé il ya cinq mois elle est à
l'heure actuelle on sait qu aucun
comportement aucune exposition
environnementale ou alimentaires nommé
les néo brunswickois en danger on écarte
la possibilité qu'une toxine présente
dans l'environnement ou l'alimentation
et rendu les gens malades l'affirmation
choc les familles qui mettent en doute
la validité de l'enquète il peut pas
faire une décision seulement avec
utiliser les questionnaires de 30
personnes comment peux tu dire qu'il ya
aucun problème il va vivre au marteau
avec ockrent est la conclusion de
l'enquêté épidémiologique est
essentiellement basée sur un sondage
téléphonique effectué auprès de 34 des
48 patients de la grappe ce sondage nous
apprend que 91 % des répondants
consommer des aliments sauvages que 97%
et consommer des fruits de mer jusqu'à
deux ans avant le début des symptômes et
suite au questionnaire épidémiologique
aucun test supplémentaire n'a été
demandé à ma connaissance
je suis sidéré qu'ils aient dit
publiquement qu'il n'y avait rien dans
l'alimentation ni dans l'eau alors qu
aucune investigation n'a eu lieu waouh
c'est absurde parce que leur rapport
souligne passante âge élevé de gens qui
consomment certains aliments
je crois que c'était juste pour dire aux
gens du nouveau brunswick ne vous
inquiétez pas il n'y a rien là
c'était pas un point de presse c'est un
spectacle
comme ça que je me sentais c'était
décourageant
karl clark ne comprend pas l'absence du
docteur marc ayrault qui disparaît peu à
peu du paysage médiatique
où était notamment riz rond le principal
intéressé
sont nommés pendant la conférence de
presse la ministre laisse planer le
doute sur la validité du travail du
docteur
46 et 48 cas ont été référées par un
seul neurologue une investigation sur
une grappe potentiel de personnes
atteintes d'un syndrome neurologique
devrait être impartial je suis au milieu
d'une tempête je sens qu'il ya de la
diffamation
volontaire et planifier ce qu'on veut
dire c'est que ça doit être étudié par
plus d'un urologue
de conclure qu'il existe une maladie
neurologique inconnu et en hommes c'est
un peu prématuré le
docteur marc ayrault refuse de voir son
hypothèse balayée aussi facilement je me
dis qu'il faudrait d'autres tests et
qu'il faut tester on peut pas faire
pleins destination doute un problème
neurologique grave avec des entrevues
téléphoniques
selon lui les conclusions de l'enquêté
épidémiologique son questionnable et les
autopsies pratiquées sont incomplètes
on m'a demandé de consentir avec les
familles des fringues non pas seulement
le cerveau mais aussi des biopsies des
reins des tissus gras et deux fois afin
de tester les toxines il y avait ça en
interne d'échantillons qui dorment dans
le laboratoire deux experts qui nous ont
parlé hors caméra pense aussi que des
tests plus approfondis aurait pu être
fait dans le cadre des autopsies afin de
déceler les traces d'un nouveau syndrome
neurodégénératifs date par le big ask et
ce n'est pas trop demander que les
tissus des personnes décédées soit testé
pour des toxines un manteau food et bros
ça n'a pas été fait benton
le top seed le riz biti a révélé qu'il
souffrait d'alzheimer mais ces enfants
dit les teams sont convaincus que ce
n'est pas cette maladie qui a emporté
leurs pairs en moins de cinq mois
des suisses sans ping c'était quelque
chose de différent c'était rapide vers
le discount mais aussi le d'éclat
n'était pas
une petite
mais toute une descente de schio en
mémoire de leur père les beats y ont
lancé une campagne de bracelet qu'il
distribue aux familles ils veulent faire
pression pour que les recherches pour
trouver la cause de la maladie reprenne
on a choisi le violet le blanc les
couleurs du nouveau brunswick le message
inscrit et la recherche c'est l'espoir
et c'est ironique parce que c'est
exactement ce qui manque présentement la
recherche une chose certaine selon les
beatty la décision du nouveau brunswick
de faire cavalier seul des cartes et le
fédéral et le docteur marc ayrault
n'êtes pas les patients
il n'y a pas de place pour
l'indifférence et l'attitude négative
nous avons besoin de réponses mais un
seul et il faut travailler ensemble
[Musique]
arrivé à l'hôpital toronto western luc
leblanc rencontre la docteure lorraine
kalia une spécialiste de la maladie de
parkinson
luc est un des patients que le docteur
marc ayrault soupçonne de souffrir du
nouveau syndrome est ici pour obtenir un
deuxième avis médical est l'endroit
le plan avec monsieur leblanc
aujourd'hui est de reprendre du début
et de poser un nouveau regard sur son
dossier
imagerie du cerveau examen cognitifs et
neuropsychologiques rencontre avec un
spécialiste des commotions cérébrales
luc leblanc va passer 16 heures en
évaluation trois jours plus tard c'est
l'heure de vérité
avec tous les morceaux du casse-tête que
nous avons rassemblé jusqu'ici nous
pouvons affirmer qu'il n'est pas atteint
de cette maladie neurologique
dégénérative un progression rapide
selon docteur kalia les symptômes de
l'ucl blanc sont probablement liée à la
commotion cérébrale qu'il a subie trois
ans plus tôt
je me sens soulagé
ces trois derniers jours ont été lents
docteur kalia tient cependant à faire
une mise en garde
il est le seul qui nous a raconté son
histoire et que nous avons évalué
[Musique]
malheureusement nous ne pouvons pas nous
prononcer sur les autres patients lance
luc leblanc ne veut pas que son cas soit
utilisé pour démontrer qu'il n'y a pas
de nouveaux syndromes au nouveau
brunswick il se considère comme une
exception il va avoir une maladie
mystérieuse à centaine à certains un
accord dans les 48 mois en cause c'était
du sport c'est injuste horatio le
docteur marc ayrault n'a pas voulu
commenter l'évaluation de la docteure
kalia sur un cas spécifique est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous croyez qu'il y ait
encore une maladie neurologique inconnu
du couac est une maladie inconnue
pour laquelle je vois des plus sains
plus décalé plus en plus des jeunes qui
doivent avoir un diagnostic et qui
mérite avoir une recherche approfondie
pas des équipes d experts dans le
domaine au niveau national et même
international
donc non seulement vous y croyez encore
mais vous croyez que ça prend de
l'ampleur je suis convaincu simplement
de l'ampleur parce que je le vois
cliniquement
malgré tout les revirements la confiance
de carole clark envers le docteur marc
ayrault et inébranlable
me ferez pas changé d'idée
à moins d'être certain de diagnostic ne
dira rien
c'est un homme intègre
un excellent neurologue
[Musique]
roger liste de son côté recommence à
manger et à prendre du poids mais la
maladie semble continuer de gagner du
terrain je sais avec le scan qui était
fait son cerveau dans le mois de
septembre
il ya des régions dans son cerveau qui
est plus fort qu'avant les familles
lycées clarke comme plusieurs autres se
sentent abandonnés par le système de
santé le vide laissé par l'absence de
réponse concrète de la province a fait
place à la mobilisation
les gens du nouveau brunswick doivent
agir maintenant c'est une belle province
avec de belles plages d en accueillant
impliquez-vous c'est pas une histoire
inventée nous sommes tous malades et ça
va de mal en pis selon le docteur marc
ayrault il faut questionner le refus du
gouvernement du nouveau brunswick de
collaborer avec tous ceux qui cherchent
des réponses il réclame que toute la
lumière soit faite sur la place publique
il serait pertinent d'avoir une
commission d enquête sur ce sujet pour
mettre au point ce qui n'a pas été dit
hall 1 ce que les tests qui n'ont pas
été fait et pourquoi on met soudainement
des côtes et les scientifiques fédéraux
et nous mêmes les médecins en premier
league c'est trop grave pour qu'on les
considère comme des baguettes de points
mais j'espère que le dossier va
progresser et que les autres patients ne
subiront pas le même sort que mon père
enso n'en faudrait pour mon père c'est
trop tard
mais pour eux il ya de l'espoir tel ce
groupe
stevie lise porte le bracelet de steam
et jill beatty de projets dans il est
devenu militant on a des plans pour
créer un pétition publique pour demander
à leurs gouvernements de travailler avec
les départements fédéraux
il a créé un groupe facebook où se
retrouvent les victimes et leurs
familles le groupe compte aujourd'hui
plus de 500 membres je me bats promo
premièrement mais deuxièmement c'est
pour gabriel elle est trop jeune pour
être malade ça fait sept mois maintenant
que gabriel a appris qu'elle était
potentiellement atteintes du nouveau
syndrome
elle n'espère qu'une chose retrouver sa
vie d'avant loin des jeux de pouvoir
entre la science et la politique ou à
retourner bon mes amis qui commence la
troisième année un génocide est
immonde radieux pour le temps qu'elle
j'ai rapporté autant que je guéris mao
j'ai encore de l'espoir qu'est ce que je
pourrais tomber
[Musique]
j'ai encore l'espoir des fois
là
[Musique]